there are a few rifles that have become
iconic must-haves in our video games
such as the M16 and the AK but while the
scar is younger and its list of pop
culture entries fewer over the last few
years the weapon is making every effort
to enter the Arsenal of essential
virtual Firearms but does it deserve to
we're here at the Royal armories talking
to Jonathan Ferguson to break down a bit
of the history of the scar its
appearances in games and movies as well
as ending with a bit of a surprise for
Jonathan
foreign
is pretty cemented in video games now
but it's it's history isn't even that
long I think people can be forgiven to
think it's a much older gun than it is
with how many games it's been in so can
you take us through a sort of brief
history of the scar sure yeah I think
the details are not too many at least
not this side of the Atlantic but there
was a U.S I guess Department of Defense
solicitation as they call it in late
2003 this is for Socom Special
Operations Command so they wanted their
own
assault rifle to replace specifically
the M4A1 which is the heavier barreled
automatic version of the M4 they wanted
to go ground up carry over what worked
from the AR come up with something
that's suited for Special Operations
forces specifically and then by about
2008 what we know is the Special
Operations forces combat assault rifle I
believe was its original yeah what came
first like that full title or the
acronym do they want to call something a
scar and was like how do we how do we
make that fit because it feels too much
like a coincidence that it has this cool
name and it just happens to fit in that
this is one of those things I'd love to
get hold of one of the people involved
and ask the question because we don't
know but I'm pretty sure it's a silly
Macho name and then they retrofitted
some terms to fit the important point to
make I suppose is that scar is the
program and this is just what one right
so there were other submissions and if
you dig around you you can find examples
and as a trial held about which we know
very little and this is what wins and
the main difference I think that that
people
um like playing games sort of know is
the H and the L
so what are the main differences between
sort of the two scar variants that we
see in games so much this is not
something that FN came up with this was
built into the original solicitation for
this new rifle But whichever variant
design was chosen from the company that
submitted it
it would have to come in two flavors the
H or heavy is what's here on the stand
um if you're ever
trying to identify them look at the
magazine if it's a big chunky deep one
like this it's your 762 caliber H or
heavy and then slightly hidden by
this Arrangement here
is the much skinnier mag of the 556
variant which is the light or l so
what's quite interesting is you know we
were looking into its appearances in pop
culture and the first appearance is tied
quite closely to just when public
knowledge about the scar sort of became
prominent like the first few games like
sold in the secret Wars that's you know
a pretty obscure game that features a
lot of weapons it was in Battlefield 2
and at the time that Battlefield was was
huge and that I think was the first time
that a sort of virtual Spotlight was
shown on this weapon since then it's had
like Rainbow Six it's been in so many
Cod games video games latched onto it so
quickly they immediately saw something
new and interesting and put it in the
games so fast and after that just so
many more games besides period in when
we talk about um weapons appearing in
pop culture I think some are more
closely tied to cinema some are more
closely tied to video games it's a
weapon that is primarily video game
famous in in
yeah I mean it's it's appearances in
movies I think it was like a background
weapon for the Swiss guard in Angels and
Demons of all things yeah and then I
didn't know that I think it appeared an
Inception briefly but I do remember yeah
you mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling but those aren't films
where there's there's too many big
firefights the action isn't the main
point but for video games I think like I
said they latched onto this very quickly
and I think aesthetically it's very
different especially when games sort of
lean into the tan variant which I'm
going to say it's brown yeah and that's
that's contrast to just just black and
wood stuff that I think is is normally
found in our games and I think you know
there's actually very few games that
have the black variant but is the tan
variant also the most sort of popular
one in reality as well or is it a case
of like well we need it to be visually
different and not lost in the sea of
other black guns that we have yeah the
the fashion side of the industry I think
is is fascinating and a bit overlooked
we tend to assume that especially with
military Firearms it's all driven by you
know sheer practicality and looks don't
matter well that's just nonsense
especially with Special Operations
forces and of course everyone looks up
effectively to those forces for their
kit and tactics and everything else so
in short I think um I think that was
very important and has become weirdly
one of its features and it's set the
trend everyone's fighting in the desert
at that time or Western forces are
fighting in the desert they want
something that breaks up the outline of
the weapon better than just black and
yeah now everything is almost by default
available in some variation of these
colors often they have trouble matching
the colors so each gun is about four
three or four different shades of brown
it's interesting you mentioned the
Special Forces aspect because I think in
um one Warfare 2 it's a weapon carried
by like Task Force 141 like the upper
echelon of people as it first
appearances it was sort of reserved for
the Special Forces character characters
enemies to sort of I think separate them
from sort of other and other NPCs that
you might have been seeing
but it's quite often a late level unlock
a weapon you get quite deep into a game
implied sort of Rarity like that in
games it's a little thing that Taps into
the sort of the Special Forces element
of things and just makes it feel that
much like more Gucci more hard to come
by more more reserved for the important
combatants I guess yep which is of
course a deliberate reflection of its
Origins and Its Real World issue I mean
my impression is that as time has gone
on it's become more just another option
and a lot of Special Forces have not
gone with it so it hasn't become the
signature weapon for Special Forces but
equally it's been a success it hasn't
gone away you know the AR and the AK
Still dominate but this thing is there
it's sort of a benchmark as well a lot
of new designs the CZ brand two off the
top of my head is essentially a parallel
universe Scar and I always talked about
the modularity being very important when
it comes to like the the production of
this weapon like you can see scope ropes
grenade launchers we've seen examples
before with you know four grips and
laser sights and everything and I think
that was very important as games sort of
built up to add more modularity as well
they had a new interesting weapon that
also fit in with what they were trying
to accomplish with games like we did a
whole episode of attachments and how
they gained in popularity so it made a
lot of sense that game shooters were
like well it's new it's interesting it's
visually different and we can throw cool
stuff on it legitimately yeah and and
not have it sort of look out of place
like all of this ties together and and
looks right especially with you know the
grenade launcher and games tap into that
like you know pubg getting a lot of
attachments you're going to improve it
mid-2000s as Call of Duty was growing
unlock more attachments and a lot more
attachments a lot more attachments even
even Battlefield and just allowing you
to customize your firearming in game
became like a huge drawing point to
developers and what the scar was doing
right came at the right time in at least
video game terms and really lent itself
two games to the virtual world with how
much you can do with it and how
different it is I suppose the the the
main thing that sort of gets lost in
some of the games is that the L firing
the 556. how did that compare to the to
the M4 firing the the same cartridge in
in reality because in games it sort of
changes from game to game but there are
some there are some patterns that have
emerged through some games between its
comparison to the M4 and the L and the H
variant that's a very interesting
question with a lot of real world
resonance because
it's not different enough
[Applause]
this thing emerges into the into the
public eye and as you say almost
immediately into pop culture in about
2008 but very quickly the L just Falls
away so the stories of unreliability and
teething problems as you would get with
any new weapon system if I can use that
term but the only thing that that sticks
as far as U.S Socom are concerned at
least is the mark 17 the SCAR H
this thing
is too close to an M4A1 they already had
the M4A1 the mark 18 Close Quarter
battle receiver version as well it just
wasn't worth sticking with for them it's
interesting to sort of mirrors its life
in games as well like in in some games
it's basically just a replacement for
the M4 it doesn't add much Variety in
gameplay when it's when it's limited to
the to the L when versions of the scar
are added into a game it's usually the H
and I think the H is getting more more
popular in games and it's the one
developers will prefer because it can
add variety recoil will be higher and
rate of fire will be a little slower
obviously a much smaller magazine
potentially higher damage with a bigger
cartridge and you know it might be only
small adjustments to the in-game stats
but it at least feels different and it's
strange because I don't know if it's on
purpose like game developers also
realizing the L isn't doing much for us
in our games whereas the H is first
person shooters are not typically quote
unquote realistic but the base starts as
you say of equivalent accuracy however
that's depicted rate of fire I mean if
anything the the rate of fire on these
is slower so if you were to replace your
M4 and Mark 18
with the equivalent scar l it'd be less
fun to use because it's more like 650
rounds per minute not not 800 plus yeah
in the real in the real world that's a
good thing you want more controllable
automatic fire if you're going to have
it in games it's just less fun
um but yeah there's just not enough to
differentiate it unless you start
massaging your stats
the basic way in which guns are depicted
in games
follows reality enough that I can see
that it is because it's too similar to
an M4 in reality and in game world
that it's just not doing enough but for
me there's a few sort of notable games
that it's appeared in like I remember I
have fond memories of it in Battlefield
3 and it interestingly enough it was it
was a weapon that's that appeared in
Battlefield first and then Call of Duty
stars to grab onto it a few weapons are
found there they're Fame in one shooter
and another's taken note but
interestingly like the the most current
sort of Fame that this weapon carries
I think weirdly is fortnite
and I'm not it's it's it's straight even
I am aware of this yeah because it's
it's strange because the fortnite
version is it's like legendary Rarity of
the assault rifle which replaces the M4
when you when you upgrade it so it's
sort of weirdly mirroring reality and
it's Aesthetics I think because it's
very blocky lends itself to that sort of
cartoonish
air of fortnite
um which is something that we can
actually
uh showcase as a little surprise I love
it when you surprise me with the with a
Nerf variant and it's I mean
yeah it's weird but like you can you can
see it it's even got like the flip up
sights
and it's just for me very bizarre that
this it's become like the poster weapon
of the of the game because of its Rarity
it's it's an assault rifle class so it's
like probably the common most common
weapon type in the game I mean obviously
fortnite has propelled it to such Fame
that it's now
that thing
there we go I will hit the camera yeah
a lot of fun there you go there's a half
a MAG there for you amazing but it is
interesting that finger off the trigger
at all times yeah good discipline it is
interesting that this you know sort of
Scar badass name it's most famous now
for fortnite it's
I don't I don't think that's what
um f and hustle really imagined I'm sure
it was but I bet they don't mind their
guns famous for being one of the biggest
video game games in the world probably
not I mean the way the way things go
it's it's conceivable that even the SCAR
H falls out of at least
Socom yes and and so this video because
of the Curve magazine
the judge
I'm happy to leave this here if you want
to get a little tag on it leaving the
collection
um doing it following the wrong hands so
well quite it's clearly very dangerous
uh this is in all seriousness this is
something that we we've considered
moving toward but it's a case of where
to start and where to stop so we have a
stand here start and stop here maybe no
um we have a good collection now of
popular culture staff stuff that's been
in movies TV we have yet to really
represent the gun in video gaming and we
need to do that with at least one object
so it is not impossible I could find
myself doing the uh the paperwork
for something like this and hey fortnite
what could be bigger and the biggest
fortnite gun just so happens to be a
scar
complete with the legendary Ugg boot
shaped buttstock yep I've said
collapsing very similar
that's yours now
I'm taken with it to be honest
I just shoot the camera
middle finger on that button oh we have
a grip safety effectively
foreign
we're gonna go off and reload them